brazil is one of the largest countries
in the world
it's known for its incredible
biodiversity
there's the amazon rainforest in the
north
the east is dominated by lagoons and
stunning beaches
the legendary copacabana
and sugarloaf mountain
and in the south the pampas
for the past four years the brazilian
economy has been booming
education is improving and a new middle
class is emerging
but brazil is plagued by transportation
problems
the 2014 fifa world cup in brazil is
just around the corner
but what's the best way for fans to get
to and from the matches
can brazil overcome its problems in time
a company in the german city of
stuttgart hopes to alleviate brazil's
traffic chaos
the organization cities for mobility is
based here patrick dauda coordinates
mobility projects across the globe
the fact that germany was the host
nation of the 2006 world cup is of
interest to many members of the network
particularly those from brazil because
we can pass on our experiences to the
host
cities was built in the middle of the
jungle and is only accessible by boat or
plane
the city's iconic amazon theater is a
relic from its glorious past
today manaus has grown to encompass 1.8
million inhabitants but the city can't
boast a world-class football stadium
that's set to change
the german architectural firm gerkan
mark on partner has been given the job
of designing a new stadium here their
specialists in the field and built
stadiums for the world cups in germany
and south africa
fork hot pick lived in south africa for
several years
now he's in manaus and responsible for
the new arena to amazonia
this was once the site of an old stadium
all the old steel girders and seeds were
painstakingly removed and reused
elsewhere
it's all very innovative so a lot of
attention has been paid to the
environment even with all the building
waste
the earth is decontaminated over there
and then reused here
conditions in the jungle are extreme
it's hot it's humid and heavy rains can
strike without warning the stadium has
to be built quickly
the architects found inspiration for its
design from the structures colors and
forms in the amazon rainforest
the image that everyone will soon be
seeing on television during the world
cup and which will also be a landmark
we've tried to use structures from
nature as a model biological structures
there's nothing like this net the steel
roofing frame in the whole world
wants to be known as a green city
authorities want to reduce the
environmental impact of the stadium so
material will be sourced from nearby
waste will be recycled and rain water
collected
but even transporting the material
presents a challenge
in the amazon most of the transportation
is by water i think 80 percent of the
population is connected to the city by
the waterways in other words there are
no major roads here logistically that
means we'll have to bring all of the
large construction components in by
water
yeah
roads will be extended by the time the
world cup kicks off
but the amazon and its tributaries are
still the region's greatest asset
the people of amazonia rely on the river
for food and water but if they fall ill
they have no means to cross the expanses
of water to receive treatment
then the river can become an obstacle
to overcome this authorities have
devised an elaborate system of small
ambulance boats known as ambulances
there are nine of these docks located
along the length of the rio negro
in the event of a medical emergency the
boats can pick up the patient and take
them for treatment
afterward they're transferred to smaller
boats and taken home
for the river people it's often the only
way they can get medical help
osvaldo chagas was taken to hospital
with heart problems
if i had taken the ferry it would have
been nine or ten hours until i was
treated
with this ambulance you only need
between two and two and a half hours
his condition took a turn for the worse
the pain in his chest returned but
luckily a doctor and nurse are always on
board
today ribera martial is doing the rounds
i want to help people when they're in
need i chose emergency medicine because
those are the moments in which the
patient is most fragile it's this thin
line between life and death
and i think i can offer every single
person the correct treatment at that
moment
back in stuttgart patrick dauda and his
colleagues are giving the delegation
from brazil a guided tour of the city's
traffic management center
ralph thomas is in charge here
you can see a traffic jam on this
display we have a three-stage display
denoted by different colors
red means there's a traffic jam
as you can see here on the bridge
yellow means there's heavy traffic and
green means the traffic is flowing
freely
here we have the traffic monitoring
camera on the bridge
stuttgart has valuable experience and
everyone is keen to pass on their
knowledge
it's possible to implement this system
in brazil too
that means immediately establishing a
traffic management center maybe not on
the same scale as in stuttgart but a
scaled down version
and you can manage the private and
public transport in one management
center
the city of puerto alegre will be the
site of a new traffic management center
like the one in stuttgart
it'll be the first of its kind in the
country
patrick dauda is offering advice to
carla meineke the center's director she
was trained in stuttgart for a month and
is already putting her training into
practice
there are 41 cameras located throughout
the city to monitor traffic and the
city's taxis help too
they've been fitted with gps devices to
collect data on traffic conditions
we've also fitted infrared beams so we
can carry out traffic counts and
identify possible variations that would
require a change in the timing of the
traffic lights
and what is different here in comparison
to all other capital cities is that 92
percent of traffic lights are controlled
from this room that's nearly one hundred
percent everything can be controlled
from here
is impressed
they also want the police to be here
with them which isn't yet the case
if they were they would be able to react
better and even quicker to certain
situations the way they're working here
seems very well thought out and very
professional
but the city also faces another
challenge
carrosas are a common sight on the
streets of porto alegre they are small
horse-drawn farm carts used by slum
dwellers to transport trash
their drivers not only present a danger
to other road users but also to
themselves
but the inhabitants of the slums live
off the money that the trash provides
many have no other choice
this is the villa chocolate most of the
people in this slum also live off trash
collecting
authorities are trying to help they
deliver trash to the slums to keep the
carosas off the streets
and they're also building a hall where
it can be
recycled terrazinia de silva is 33 years
old she's worked here for 13 years but
also used to collect trash
when we used to work on the streets we
earned a lot less
that was because of the price as the
quality wasn't very good
and we didn't separate the trash very
well
normally you separate the trash quickly
and then sell it
but here we separate it properly and
that helps us to get a better price so
now we earn more
things have improved a lot but i hope
the future will be even better after we
start to use the new hall
to give the slum dwellers a new
perspective authorities have built a new
housing complex for them and it'll soon
be ready to move in
banja gonsalves is a unesco ambassador
she's a familiar face in the slums and
people here trust her
and it happens across the world wherever
there is poverty people are moved from
one place to another
for me it's a big mistake
when the people get there how can they
survive what can they do often they
return to the streets and carry on
living as before
a house on its own doesn't solve the
problem
the solution comes when these people
change their lives so they can survive
in their new surroundings
resettlement only makes sense if people
know how to cope in their new
surroundings even the most basic skills
are important
here you can see a communal toilet in
villa
there are others but the inhabitants can
learn how to use a toilet here
it's important because when they move
into their new apartments they have to
know how to use a toilet properly
today they still do their business in a
bag and then throw it away
the toilets are a way of teaching the
inhabitants of the villa chocolato the
basics of hygiene
basic but indispensable knowledge for
their new life in better surroundings
this is rio de janeiro's famous
mountainous cityscape
down below the city's affluent
population lives and works
above them the slums
the slums in rio de janeiro are built on
the mountains for decades the people
living here have been forced to make the
arduous journey up and down the
mountainside
75 year old irosema gonsalves is one of
them
we need about an hour to get down to the
bottom fill up the water container and
then make our way up again
i lived here my hut was here yes it took
a while then by the time you had
recovered you had to set off again to
fill up another 12 liter container
sometimes there was no water and we had
to look for some back then everything
was very difficult but gradually things
have improved
today the area is changing in ways she
could never have imagined a cable car is
being built to ferry people directly to
the metro or downtown rio
moreno is overseeing the project he's
the president of the state-owned company
responsible for public works
you can get him out more quickly
to get from fazadinya to ipanema
nowadays
you need about 40 minutes
before you needed about two and a half
hours
so you save time two hours both ways
every day
anyone who lives in fazzadinya and works
in ipanema saves four hours a day
that's a lot of time
the complex
was long considered one of rio's most
dangerous slums
at the end of 2010 the military moved in
and ejected drug dealers and other
criminals from the neighborhood
the area is now a shining example of
what can be achieved when people help
themselves
in brazil it's often the women who fight
hardest for change
for nilseia rocha the cable car is a
dream come true
it's the best thing to happen to this
community
we can't quite believe it
once there was only trash
ditches full of water and dirty children
here
these people now have apartments that
give them a bit of dignity
and our district of morodos has become a
symbol of honor and tourism in the
region
it's really moving
for me it's a victory and it's a great
blessing that i'm able to experience
this here
because you never know what tomorrow
brings
today irasema gonsalves is visiting her
grandson and great-grandson
bruno itan is joining them
he's only 22 years old but has already
established himself as the
neighborhood's foremost photographer
his photos depict life here as it really
is and that's what sets them apart
i was inspired to take photos by the
community itself the complex of
is really stunning it's magical i've
always taken photographs here even
before when drug dealing was rampant and
afterwards i grew up here
right in the center the community here
is incredible they're really nice people
and their stories are beautiful
no other slum in rio has gone through
such a dramatic transformation as the
complex odo alamo
the special thing here is the happiness
of the residents and of course the cable
car which has now become the symbol of
the complex of the alamo
i don't think there's anything else like
this in the whole country
it's a really good thing
back in stuttgart the brazilian
delegation is getting a guided tour of
the mercedes-benz museum
some 1 500 cars spread over 16 000
square meters trace the history of the
automobile
lincoln paiva is president of the
traffic consultancy firm green mobility
brazil's gross domestic product is
growing by seven to eight percent
that's why there's such a big demand for
transport here
a problem that we have in brazil is that
we don't do anything to manage our
transport
what we're doing here in germany is
trying to understand how germany plans
how it manages to sell so many cars and
still keep its transport under control
sao paulo is brazil's biggest and most
congested city
11 million people live in the downtown
area alone and they own 7 million cars
right next to the cathedral is the
estassau say metro station
eight hundred thousand people use the
red metro line every day it's the
busiest in brazil and always overcrowded
corinthians itakere is the last stop the
place where the new world cup stadium is
to be built
the line will ferry fans to and from the
games there
if the stadium is ever built
people see the metro as a flagship
project in sao paulo
but you can see how overcrowded it is
and it's not even rush hour
we need more investment
the metro has to be expanded more bus
lanes have to be built and cars need to
stay off the roads
public transport has to be
improved in brazil it's expensive bad
and always overcrowded
it seems to be doing its best to lose
the trust of the people
the sao paulo metro is 60 kilometers
long that's not enough but no one knows
which line should be expanded
the city also doesn't have a stadium
ready to host a world cup game
should an existing stadium be enlarged
or is it better to start from scratch
no one knows
what they do know is where a new stadium
could be built
here in the middle of nowhere at the
itakera terminus
at the moment the site is dangerous but
big things are planned here next door a
new university is already being built
german company siemens is installing new
trains on the line the trains and their
tracks have all been checked by
germany's safety organization toof
on the yellow metro line only modern
trains are in service
they're seen as a big improvement
the first important thing to say about
this line is that it's driverless it
doesn't need a driver the system is
operated completely by computer and
other electronic systems that's the
biggest difference with this line there
are also other differences such as an
end-to-end aisle as you can see here
also the doors on the station open
simultaneously with the train doors for
safety reasons
this is the hotel unique in pineros
outside lincoln paiva and his co-worker
zhao amaral have found a novel way
around sao paulo's never-ending traffic
jams
they've come up with something never
seen before in brazil
a sightseeing tour by bicycle
today's tour will last two hours and
take these sightseers through the villa
madalena sao paulo's artistic and
bohemian quarter
the group's first stop is the museo
brasileiro de escultura an open air
museum showcasing alternative and
contemporary art
the museum has no doors so there's time
for a quick look around
with much more to see the group sets off
for the next stop on their tour
a well-hidden attraction in sao paulo is
the becco samsaida a dead-end street
adorned with graffiti
there are others like it dotted around
the city
the tour guide says the best way to see
them is by bicycle
shortly if you don't have a life or a
routine where you use the car every day
and you you stay at home of course you
get a lot of weight and people say well
instead of using the bicycle to lose
that weight they keep on doing keeping
their routine on the car as to gain even
more weight so of course it all you
always have to begin and it's always
going to be tougher in the beginning but
then you're going to see the results
we bring it here especially to show the
culture of the street art and show uh
one of the best characteristics here in
uh villa madalena which is that some
hidden places uh in sao paulo that
people normally don't know and that they
don't even have an idea that this
place exists
what makes the villa madalena so special
is that it grew naturally unlike other
towns and cities in brazil
there are a lot of small unique shops
here
shops like this one
inside it's like taking a trip back in
time to the 1950s
it's another stop on the tour that
lincoln paiva is proud of
at first the idea had nothing to do with
the world cup the idea was to create a
sustainable means of transport for sao
paulo
and for other cities in general we
wanted to offer an alternative so that
people use their cars less
but we also want to use the world cup in
the olympic games just as other cities
across the world have used them to
improve our transportation network
germany is a good example of that
the tour rounds off with a visit to a
tea house it's a great place for tea
connoisseurs
there are more than three dozen
different blends on offer here all of
them grown organically
it's the perfect end to a sportier kind
of tour
in pakayambu stadium the fans of the
corinthians palista football club are
warming up for their showdown with arch
rival sao kaitano
brazilian football fans are unrivaled in
their love and passion for the game but
that can sometimes make them difficult
to control
the stadium here dates back to 1938 and
is a long way off the stringent
standards required to host a world cup
game
but this is where the tournament's
opening match will be kicking off so the
pachaimbu stadium will have to be
completely renovated
that's as long as authorities don't
decide on a new stadium instead
football fans here don't think the
tournament will be a success
i'm the kind of guy who believes in many
things but i doubt we'll be able to
stage a world cup on a par with the one
in germany germany is a first world
country and everything there was a
hundred percent safety transport
everything every stadium could be
reached with the metro i look around
here and think we can't have the world
cup here when i consider what i saw in
germany
at least for us here in brazil football
is everything football is love it's
happiness it's religion football makes
football fans happy
over a thousand kilometers to the
southwest in puerto alegre two teams are
battling it out in a penalty shootout
the league title is at stake and it's
brazilians high flyers international who
take the glory
patrick dauda reflects on his time in
brazil
i really like brazil there's just a
great atmosphere here people have lots
of enthusiasm and i've already seen some
of that they're motivated and i think
they'll manage to get everything ready
in time for the world cup there are
still a couple of technical things left
to do but i'm sure they'll manage
everything in any case it's a great
country with great people and i really
enjoyed it
wow
you